[Aplausos]
[Música]
en los últimos tiempos han crecido como
la espuma las dudas los mitos y también
las preocupaciones sobre cómo será el
empleo en el futuro especialmente en los
países desarrollados la robótica la
inteligencia artificial la inmigración
la competencia internacional
[Música]
según muchas personas vamos a tener que
acostumbrarnos a un futuro donde el
trabajo sea un lujo y el desempleo
masivo la situación normal para la
mayoría de las personas
un mundo en definitiva amigos donde las
desigualdades serán mucho mayores y la
precariedad laboral una especie de
cláusula irrenunciable para quien tenga
ojo la suerte de poder trabajar
[Música]
y no sólo eso prácticamente las mismas
personas que defienden todas estas tesis
dicen también que si no realizamos
profundos cambios y ponemos freno a este
frenético desarrollo el bienestar de
todos nosotros estará en peligro claro
si apenas hay trabajo y la riqueza y la
producción se concentran en una reducida
pero poderosa oligarquía de grandes
empresarios de que viviremos quién
pagará impuestos cómo diantres
financiaremos el estado de bienestar de
tantas personas paradas o con trabajos
tan precarios suena mal verdad casi
parece que como decirlo estamos a punto
de enfrentarnos a la tormenta perfecta
pues precisamente son muchos de estos
miedos los que han favorecido la llegada
a la política de líderes tan populistas
como donald trump o marín de pene entre
otros estos líderes políticos afirman
que nuestras sociedades
se están desmoronando o están a punto de
hacerlo y que para impedirlo ellos son
nuestra única esperanza porque tienen la
decisión de poner fin a un modelo que
nos
al desastre claro si hay una amenaza
habrá que defenderse y no no hablamos
sólo de los inmigrantes para nada
amazon está haciendo un gran daño a los
minoristas que pagan impuestos pueblos
ciudades y estados de los eeuu están
siéndo heridos muchos empleos se están
perdiendo pero esperad un momento será
verdad que estamos avanzando hacia un
futuro tan oscuro será verdad que los
robots nos quitarán nuestros empleos y
destruirán nuestra forma de vida acaso
será cierto que si no nos enterramos
detrás de grandes muros corremos el
riesgo de perder nuestros trabajos pues
bien para responder a estas preguntas y
analizar qué hay de verdad en todas
estas cuestiones o todos estos mitos
vamos a fijarnos en lo que está
ocurriendo claro en nuestro mundo pero
sobre todo en lo que está pasando en la
mayor potencia económica de la tierra en
el país más influyente si en eeuu
[Música]
fin del empleo
coches autónomos máquinas que son
capaces de aprender por sí mismas
fábricas sin trabajadores robots
inteligentes la ciencia ficción parece
estar convirtiéndose día tras día en una
realidad vayamos a fuego
[Música]
y ojo toda esta ola tecnológica no ha
hecho sino apenas comenzar la
nanotecnología la biotecnología la
ingeniería genética o la robótica
prometen cambiar para siempre el mundo
que conocemos multiplicar la
productividad y sustituir a las personas
fijaos en un informe al presidente en
2016 el consejo de asesores económicos
de los eeuu estimó que ni más ni menos
el 83 por ciento de los empleos que
pagaban menos de 20 dólares la hora
podrían ser automatizados en poco tiempo
es decir en otras palabras que los
países que más rápido desarrollen y
utilicen todo esto de la robótica serán
los primeros en sufrir grandes pérdidas
de empleo millones y millones de nuevos
parados pero un momento es este el
futuro que nos espera evidentemente el
futuro es por definición incierto pero
podemos fijarnos en lo que ya está
ocurriendo porque si ya hay robots por
ejemplo en las fábricas
pues bien si vamos a los datos veremos
que en la evidencia empírica nos dice
todo lo contrario atentos a este gráfico
los países que más robots utilizan son
precisamente los que menos desempleo
padecen
pues bien todo esto tiene una
explicación muchas veces nos fijamos
mucho en los puestos de trabajo que
desaparecen pero no vemos todos los
nuevos empleos que se crean al mismo
tiempo
[Música]
nuevos tiempos nuevos empleos
hasta ahora ha sido en la industria
donde más robots se han utilizado de
hecho algunas compañías de coches como
ford ya tienen líneas de montaje
formadas exclusivamente por robots es
decir sin trabajadores
pues bien la producción industrial de
eeuu está prácticamente en niveles
récord pero qué ha pasado con los
empleos industriales mira
[Música]
si así es si en los años 40 la industria
generaba en eeuu uno de cada tres
puestos de trabajo hoy apenas genera uno
de cada doce empleos cuatro veces menos
quiere decir esto que no hay trabajo en
eeuu para nada desde los años cuarenta
la potencia norteamericana ha generado
más de 86 millones de nuevos empleos en
el sector servicios transportes finanzas
entretenimiento etcétera etcétera
de hecho atentos nunca antes en la
historia habían trabajado tantas
personas en este país y ojo estamos
hablando de robótica pero el efecto de
cualquier tecnología es equivalente
puede que ya no exista blockbuster que
fue la empresa más grande de alquiler de
videojuegos y películas pero a cambio
tenemos netflix o sin ir más lejos
youtube y éstas son amigos empresas que
generan un montón de puestos de trabajo
también nos podemos fijar en la
industria de aplicaciones en australia
apps en australia el país de los
canguros son a casi de broma verdad pues
esperando un momento porque esta
industria
ha creado más de 113 mil puestos de
trabajo en uno de los países más ricos y
con más calidad de vida de todo el mundo
y no es sólo cosa de australia en eeuu
este sector que recordad es muy nuevo
nació hace apenas 10 años con el iphone
ha creado más de un millón y medio de
empleos bancos supermercados
aseguradoras empresas de software todas
quieren tener listas sus aplicaciones y
todo esto significa nuevos puestos de
trabajo además a medida que crece la
productividad lo normal es que las horas
de trabajo también se reduzcan
es decir que gracias a la tecnología ya
los robots trabajaremos menos horas y
eso son buenas noticias
lo creas o no en los próximos 30 años la
gente sólo trabajará 4 horas al día y
tal vez 4 días a la semana ahora la
gente visita de media 30 lugares dentro
de 30 años visitarán 300 así que parar
la globalización es imposible y tenemos
que estar preparados para ello y por
último un detalle muy importante hay
quien como bill gates ha defendido que
como los robots al fin y al cabo van a
ocupar puestos de trabajo que antes
realizaban personas de carne y hueso
pues que hay que hacerles pagar más
impuestos y sabéis que creo sinceramente
que esto es una pésima idea los robots
no son más que máquinas y tecnología y
cuantas más máquinas y tecnología
tengamos mejor viviremos los robots
amigos reducen los costes y con ellos el
precio de las mercancías gracias a ellos
los consumidores podremos trabajar menos
y comprar más por todo ello parecería
lógico pensar que los gobiernos no
tienen que dedicarse a castigar la
inversión sino a impulsarla sólo así
lograremos un mundo mejor para
todos de verdad poner nuevos impuestos a
los robots no es una buena idea al fin y
al cabo es retrasar un cambio inevitable
tenemos que prepararnos y si ahí es
donde casi todos los gobiernos están
fallando pero de eso hablaremos otro día
e
paremos la globalización
los que seguís habitualmente visual
política ya conocéis la obsesión que
nuestro amigo trump tiene con china
[Música]
y no sólo se trata de china en el último
año trampa ha acusado a canadá a méxico
a japón e incluso a corea del sur entre
otros países de competencia desleal y de
estar destruyendo puestos de trabajo en
eeuu
por eso trump quiere renegociar acuerdos
comerciales impulsar políticas
proteccionistas y llegado el caso fijar
aranceles por ejemplo en la industria
siderúrgica claro que no sería el primer
presidente de eeuu que utiliza algunas
de estas estrategias sin ir más lejos
otro republicano george bush hijo
estableció en 2002 fuertes aranceles a
las importaciones de acero el presidente
bush llevó a cabo una de las acciones
federales más intensas en dos décadas
para proteger una gran industria
americana imponiendo aranceles de hasta
el 30 por ciento en la mayoría de los
tipos de acero importa
a eeuu desde europa asia y sudamérica y
la verdad el resultado no fue nada bueno
algunos estudios cuantifican en más de
200.000 empleos los puestos de trabajo
que se perdieron con los aranceles al
acero
[Música]
tal cual como lo escucháis menos empleo
y menos competitividad también nos
podemos fijar en argentina un país donde
el proteccionismo tuvo este resultado
[Música]
por supuesto menos exportaciones
significan menos empleo pero ahí no
termina todo para nada es verdad que en
las últimas dos décadas la
deslocalización de fábricas le ha hecho
a eeuu perder muchos puestos de trabajo
pero en cierto modo gracias a ello
países como china han podido
desarrollarse y hoy sus empresarios
están deseosos de entrar a invertir en
los eeuu la mayor economía del mundo y
un lugar seguro para sus inversiones y
como decimos por aquí dicho y hecho en
2016 las empresas chinas invirtieron
casi 50 mil millones de dólares en eeuu
y hoy llaman trabajo de forma directa a
más de 140 mil estadounidenses nueve
veces más que en 2009 es el caso por
ejemplo de este empresario que estáis
viendo chau do one un tipo que en 2014
se gastó 700 millones de dólares en
rehabilitar una planta que general
motors había cerrado en ohio
y no se trata solo de las empresas
chinas uno de cada cinco estadounidenses
trabaja para empresas extranjeras y ojo
recordad que como hemos visto antes
nunca nunca antes en la historia había
habido tantas personas trabajando en
eeuu así que todo eso de que la
globalización está destrozando a
nuestras economías pues parece como que
no
[Música]
los inmigrantes y el trabajo sin lugar a
dudas lo sabéis todos esta es una de las
cuestiones más recurrentes especialmente
en los eeuu están tomando nuestros
empleos están tomando nuestros trabajos
en la industria están tomando nuestro
dinero nos están matando esto dice
donald veamos qué ocurre en la vida real
en 2016
eeuu obtuvo seis premios nobeles en
ciencia y economía
todos ellos fueron ganados por
inmigrantes personas nacidas en otro
país que hoy trabajan en las
universidades de eeuu algo que ha sido
habitual en la historia de este país no
sólo eso los inmigrantes tienden a ser
más emprendedores así que a pesar de
suponer sólo el 15% de la fuerza de
trabajo en eeuu están involucrados en
una de cada tres empresas nuevas que se
crean en este país y son precisamente
estas las empresas nuevas las que más
hacen crecer el empleo pero fijaos hay
dos tipos de inmigrantes
están los ilegales que se ocupan de las
tareas más físicas o de los trabajos que
los estadounidenses no quieren realizar
y por otro están los inmigrantes legales
de los cuales 1 de cada 2 tiene estudios
universitarios una proporción muy
superior a la de las personas nacidas en
eeuu es decir estos inmigrantes aportan
mucha materia gris son emprendedores y
en muchos casos han sido los
responsables de grandes proyectos de
éxito
procter and gamble goldman sachs yahoo
google test la american telecom intel
ebay ibm citigroup ups ahora con amazon
o incluso apple han sido algunas de las
muchas compañías fundadas o co fundadas
por inmigrantes o hijos de inmigrantes
así que como veis lo mejor de todo esto
es que los inmigrantes no solo no quitan
empleos en eeuu sino que incluso los
crean pues bien como veis muchos de los
mitos que tratan de convencernos de que
nuestros modos de vida están en peligro
no se corresponden del todo con la
evidencia pero ahora turno para ti
tienes miedo a ser sustituido en poco
con un robot déjanos tus respuestas en
los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha gustado el tema de
este vídeo dale al like y no te olvides
suscribir a visual política un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]